hey guys Mary here coming at you from
PAX East 2016 I'm here with James and
who is one half of video cult and you
guys made the coolest little game that
I've seen in quite some time I've been
seeing it over the years this is rain
world thanks for the introduction Mary
yeah we've been on this project for
about five years now and it's finally
coming to fruition being released on
Adult Swim games we're really excited
excited to talk to you about it
yeah Adult Swim is picking this up for
you guys but you guys have been a
two-man team making this game four and
you said five years about five years and
for clarification we also we have some
contractors as well we have some artists
and sound designers we're helping us out
so now we I covered this game maybe a
year ago at e3 but it's changed since
then but why don't we talk about it in
case anyone hasn't seen this before
because it might be a little different
you are a slug cat in this very strange
and dangerous world and you're eating
bats right now that's correct yeah
that's the slug cats life so in random
old you plays this cute little white
fragile little slug cat creature and
you've kind of you've been separated
from your family and you're sort of just
trying to find your way in this large
crazy world filled with hungry predators
so you kind of have to learn about the
ecosystem you have to learn about the
other creatures that exist in it and
find food sources and just try to stay
alive and and beat the rain but what are
these little yellow guys that are kind
of peeping out at you awesome events
that's part of the sort of overarching
narrative those are overseers okay and
they're kind of read you see them
earlier on but yes I have a station of
course the overseers are kind of to let
you know that there's like something
else going on in the world these guys
are like watching your movements and why
why are they watching your movements
you'll have to play the game interesting
there's a little secret throughout this
game we haven't found any of the
Predators yet but they are out there and
they are hunting you that's correct
and this is kind of a dog-eat-dog world
so even though you might prey on little
things like bats these these giant well
they look like large lizards that have
been to a nightclub they're like really
bright
color someone's call them disco lizards
just codes is a good one here there's
one and they will kill you really
quickly to Ashley they're pretty
aggressive it doesn't seem like you get
a lot of chances with those guys we've
toned them done a little bit surprised
since the last time you played it
because it was just it was just too too
brutal any fingers one of the things we
were really going for in this game is uh
the ecosystem is kind of the key like it
sort out a sword with this sandbox a
kind of art project that we were doing
right just to create like a large
believable ecosystem of creatures that
are there they have the same amount of
agency as you do there's one hiding up
there I'm gonna go poke him see if you
can move around never poke them what
okay here we go ah let me see I see I'm
the developer I should be able to do
cool things like that like poke demon
lizards but one thing I like video games
in general that I not I don't like the
fact that when a creature just exists
for you to kill it's just like an
obstacle for you to go over so all the
creatures in rain roll they're all
they're kind of all doing their own
thing like they exist perpetually
throughout the world they all have
complete agency the same amount of
agency that the player does so they're
um they're looking for food they're
getting into little territorial
squabbles there just is you know they're
in the same situations that you are
except for your delicious to them it
seems like you have put a lot of effort
into your AI of the lizards and the
creatures in this world to make
everything much more dynamic and you
really do get a sense of that especially
when you do get into these situations
when they're following you and you're
trying to trick them that you do it
differently in many different ways
all the time because you you are given
that freedom so it seems like it was
important to you guys to create a world
in which the player has the ability to
feel like they can be creative and
control the character fluidly yeah
definitely we really didn't want to
control how the player approached the
game basically you know kind of like
sandbox games sandbox themes like
minecraft has kind of changed everything
where players now you know you you want
to be able to solve problems in the way
that you think is cool and and that's
that's kind of tricky from a game design
perspective because it means you have to
have this like a large messy
but that's what we wanted to do anyways
we like large messy worlds so any way
that you can choose to you can figure
out to survive in rain world is
supported by the game if you just want
to like if you just want to farm bats
that's perfectly fine if you want to
become like a hunter or something like
that
let me see stick what the little oh it's
a little balancing precariously like on
the end of the poles are really nice
really nice touches and animations to
make everything feel very lovely oh god
he's following you alright alright and
there's another one so now I'm in
trouble
what are you doing only good like I'll
go to the next region no they will fight
each other over you yeah they definitely
will we can observe that if we want to
yeah look at that so now they're in a
little squabble even since they're
occupied all well with the matter I've
got places to be and I'm all these
environments are created this isn't like
procedural these are all like carefully
calculated environmentally yes yes
definitely that was that was one of my
big jobs there's 1,400 something rooms
okay some of them are multiple screens
and in twelve separate regions so it's
really it's a really large world now
what we are seeing and what I've seen
before is these kinds of dark
environments and urban but I know you
guys have some other stuff like other
definitely usual areas I would love to
show off some because I feel like
everyone this is these were kind of the
early regions in the game and since it's
been in development for five years
everyone has seen grey rain Road so if
you want to if you want to take it I can
zoom into some other regions share the
same stuff and yeah we I'd love to see
some new stuff let's get some color in
there I wouldn't think tell me so even
though you can just farm bats what's
like another goal that
I kind of have because it seems like
you're just kind of trying to survive
sure yeah so there's kind of an
overarching narrative of you're trying
to basically reconnect with your family
the slug cat was sort of like this the
player characters like cat was washed
away in some sort of large cataclysmic
flood and you find yourself alone in
this environment so you're kind of
trying to track down where where your
family is after this after this whole
situation me but let's show some of the
other regions we only have some we
didn't have bring put in any of the
spoiler regions but I can show some cool
stuff yeah we don't want any spoilers
know everyone's like a lovely place it
does we had we had to kind of change it
a bit because when we were showing it
off everyone was like oh skylines that
sounds lovely but it's one of the most
difficult operations so like so you
survived so now you're starting to get
into some environmental puzzles yes
where this might not look like your
standard puzzle but in many senses just
traversing this area is yes in a way a
puzzle to the player yeah definitely
yeah we call them sort of movement
puzzles and it that's exactly what it is
like you have to figure out how to
navigate yourself through this world and
the the AI creatures do as well and so
you can kind of ezra playing the game
you use your knowledge of the
environment that you've found from
coming through multiple times to your
advantage are you training the player in
particular areas where you would expect
them to be able to need to know
particular movement in order to progress
yeah definitely we we tried it we try to
do that as much as possible but it's
kind of hard it just some of it is just
gonna take some oh this is my doom oh so
I survived that fault okay
I don't know if I can get through get
out of here Mary I don't know if I'm
gonna make it oh this is a vulture and
yep you've got me there there I go
goodbye
you'll feed in horrible vulture baby yep
exactly
alright so I can show off another one
that's terrifying yeah exactly
and that's something that's another
thing that we're really key on is you
know we have we wanted to give this very
cute little creature in kind of a dark
strange environment so you and you
empathize for him daily exactly thank
you this is this is I think my favorite
of the regions which is garbage wastes
it's like a large I mean of toxic wastes
oh yeah exactly kind of I really like
the water physics and stuff like that oh
yeah you guys have done a lot with
various physics not just from water but
like the characters everything you can
see it moving and bending which makes it
feel so alive in the world you don't see
enough of that yeah definitely it's
tricky to do on that that's called a
technique that we're using for that is
called procedural animation so pretty
much all of the characters rather than
being like a sprite sheet or something
like that it's all little blobs of
physics okay
like the slug cat is kind of like a big
squishy thing with like legs and arms
sticking out of it you're not using like
bones and then just kind of pleating
them exactly blobs of goo blobs of goo
exactly how they're getting the
structural properties you guys can be
impacted by the world
vultures yeah and especially vultures so
you can see it's sort of like the tails
drape over the terrain and it's kind of
all affected like that so these little
these little worm creatures these are
called garbage worms and they're they're
like a passive fish species so though if
you're coming through and you have
weapons they'll kind of hassle you over
it okay let's see if I can that's fair I
mean you're in they're garbage
yeah exactly this is their territory
that's I'm hoping I can find some
scavengers can you utilize them or they
just they're just existing always took
my
yeah you can definitely see a big part
of the gameplay is that you can utilize
all of the creatures and your knowledge
of sort of what their likes and dislikes
are to against other creatures
essentially like the oh my god
I'm getting eaten by you were those
leeches - leeches yeah these are the
worst gross oh man I might have just
this is embarrassing I shouldn't have
dropped down here
I think I'm toast she's something this
is really bad because my inclination as
a developer is to open up the developer
tools and be like right yeah yeah
sheeting exactly but I should probably
have the players experience a really
nice way to save cheating yeah oh it's
definitely cheating yeah I'm gonna try
to find one of my one of the best
creatures literally the best feature
that sort of the crown jewel of reign
world's AI stuff and you guys are you
guys are littering these worlds with
creatures every environment has their
own different baddies and goodies and
and that's really great because it's
very it's a game all about discovery yes
yeah exactly and of the scavengers if
you can find some scavengers I don't
know it's tricky to show because since
all of the creatures have a complete
agency and they all have like a mind of
their own it's more about like herding
cats like you know if you want to show
off your cat and your cats just like not
there
that's that's the definition of brain
real basic but in the air yep exactly
Goosen there's some good stuff here
these are lights they're snails and you
can actually like it when you do that
they do not and actually go to their
agitated but I can use them if I drop
them in the water they kind of detonate
and they knock out the element the
leeches so you kind of get a lot of its
little creature interaction puzzles
where you have to figure out what each
creature does and if I don't die under
the water up here I'm good
you have a leech that's disgust there's
anything over here huh it's gonna quiet
down here I could drop some other
regions as well these are sweet thank
you thank you and you've been following
it for a long time so I it's always good
to see new stuff but part of me doesn't
want to see anything because of one of
these organically surprise yeah and well
how much longer do you guys have you
guys are at the tail end yes you can
destroy yeah definitely we have all of
the content of the game is finished all
the creatures are done everything is
pretty much put together we have like
some illustration work to do to kind of
do sort of cutscene s stuff and Taito is
it disgusting ah I think I'm thinking
too here this is a daddy longlegs I can
but I think he's gonna eat me Oh gross
okay that was that those are the worst
let's see what else would be a good one
to show but it's not all gloom and doom
either you can you um since so all the
creatures you can be dark it seems like
you've made a really beautiful cute
creature that constantly dies in the
entire world this is true but there are
also mines within this tunnel because a
lot of the creatures they sort of learn
from your interactions with them so if
you're aggressive towards the creature
it will sort of respond in kind but if
you show empathy towards the future you
can get creatures to be sort of on your
side that's really fascinating that
you're able
to add that into your game that you guys
are actually impacting the world around
you you're not just these aren't
backdrops no you're acting with your
environment exactly and over time like
your actions within the world affect how
the ecosystem changes in the future as
well if you kill a creature that like
opens up an ecological niche that like
other more dangerous potentially more
dangerous creatures from moving I don't
know I'm sure as you can tell it's so
this is actually this is one of the this
is a jet fish let me see if I can and
you can just sort of neutral although no
half will you sometimes are we all sort
of neutral yeah exactly except for
except for your friend that Oh so you
can use them as jet skis and to dive and
stuff like that to explore deeper parts
of there's a wool yes but you can't
freeze underwater so you need to get a
prayer exactly yeah you can breathe for
a little bit of time I'm kind of trying
to I want to show off there's some
really creepy stuff around here but
they're they're hiding they're busy Oh
No
let's see if this works
ah they're hassling me too much I'm
toast there you're gonna kill you I
think so they're kind of like dolphins
and that they're playful but you know I
think I saw a documentary about whales
that did really just like hey hey oh
you're dead sorry sorry mom sweet so
when can people expect to play them oh
that's a good question
um it depends on a couple of factors but
we're hoping within the next couple of
months okay yeah so within the next
couple of months you guys can look
forward to brain world and I'm
definitely looking forward to it and I
hope to see more I think definitely
well thanks very much obliged you stay
there
[Music]